hey pat
it would seem tell me if i'm wrong here
we're talking about lobbyists back to
that
paul's
almost defending lobbyists i would say
that
you would i mean as a lobbyist hello i
mean a political consultant as well you
would think that there's a role that
there's a role and that they are a net
positive to governance whereas pat
correct me if i'm wrong at the end of
the day you think lobbyists are a net
negative
to america am i wrong on that
okay so here's how i see it okay
you know the whole conversation between
sales and marketing yep
what sales what's marketing right
marketing spreads sales is one
dimensional marketing is like a story
goes out like coca-cola share a coke
with jose with adam oh my god i don't
even drink coke but hey i got this great
campaign came out of australia coke took
off they become what they become right
i think
lobbyists are the ultimate cmos
they'll do laps around cmos at major
corporations like if a major corporation
wants to hire a real good cmo go
freaking put on an ad and say i'm
looking for former lobbyists who help
somebody win i'll give you a congressman
that would have i would tell you like he
would make one hell of a cmo at a major
court and i'm being very frank with you
i mean very soon because
the strategy they take with research and
data and gathering them and telling the
story and saying it in a way where
you're like man this thing makes sense
it's a very powerful job but
ah it's the ultimate spin zone though
it's the ultimate spins in my opinion i
may be wrong and by the way let's just
say one day you get into politics if the
other guy's using lobbyists guess what
we got to get for you we got to get some
solid lobbyists on you because if you're
going to use it i have to use it you
know what i'm saying i'm not going to do
it but hey you're going to use oh we're
going to become these noble people we're
not going to use it no you have to so he
makes the point about so what do you
want to do teachers union should we get
rid of them i mean if both sides are
going to use it you have to use it okay
that that's the part where once you get
into that game
that [ __ ] is dirty and you you want to
you're going to play that game against
me watch how better of a job i'm going
to maneuver against you and you may
disagree with me but that's my
assessment on the world of lobby look i
mean i understand the point and and by
the way donald trump would agree with a
lot of what you just said um
but uh but the point is
what are you going to replace it with
i mean if you can't expect congress
especially in today's day and age to be
experts on all the things they have to
be experts on and you can't they there's
not enough staff for them the money from
the staff they would need to have an
expert on this an expert on this an
expert on this
etc so you have to have a role yeah how
you frame the
role to protect the concerns that you
have that's a different issue but the
the to say that throw the baby and the
bath water out
that's not that it's not realistic
and it frankly i think is harmful to the
system i disagree with a lot of what the
teachers union stand for as far as what
they think they can do with the with our
kids in school but i see a role for them
and they're massive bullies though well
they are teachers they're massive
bullies because they have the power to
be a massive bill yeah so that but but
again it goes back because we've
empowered them i think in 1807 i don't
know what the year was when they were
trying to eliminate lobbies and create
laws and all this stuff so it's been
going on for a while where you know they
knew this was eventually because some of
these guys were going to become more
powerful than actual presidents
congressmen and senators some lobbies
are more powerful than you know jim
baker you've read his book i'm sure
you've read it if you haven't read this
book i couldn't put the book down by the
way some of the stuff he was talking
about in there on the stories of what
happened you know jim baker is more
powerful than
most of these guys that became president
jim he could have become a president but
he chose to play a different role you
know
yeah i think
again i think i think lobbyists
in a big way make the political world
well you know what you know i just
thought of it with first lobbyists
because you you at one point said
well they represent industries because
abuse by the way you said industries
lobbyists represent industry we met
initially at an insurance conference
yeah album 10 years ago
that's probably the biggest brokerage uh
industry meeting there's another one
called aalu you're probably familiar
with that yes uh they've changed their
name since then but it's the insurance
advocacy group in dc every year the
meeting is in dc we're in the insurance
business financial services business the
whole point of that meeting is to get
all the insurance people to dc
to do our meeting and then what do they
all do go to the hill to meet with our
congressmen to basically
uh
promote the importance of insurance and
you know financial wellness in the
family so there is
there is an upside you know even to us
but but the reason why they need that
because on the other side elizabeth
warren's got the best of the best was
lobbying against hurting people in the
financial industry so you have to have
the counter attack that's why i'm
exactly my point earlier right if you're
going to use it i have to hire this
lobbyist and that's what he's saying is
that like you can't you can't trust the
baby with the bathwater right
i don't disagree with you that part and
and you know and yes there are excesses
yeah
um
again part of my biggest problem
with and why i think why i believe that
trump was going to win in 2016 was
because
you washington becomes
segmented segregated segregated and they
focus on what's in their interest and
not in the people whose interests that
they are representing meaning the
american people um and it bothers me and
i got out of american politics until for
about eight years when i was over in
ukraine because i was fed up with being
part of a system where when people got
elected and came to washington
they didn't worry about
their promises as much as they worried
about building a power base inside
washington and that was true republicans
and democrats
and and the hypocrisy that i said a
minute ago using the filibuster example
but that is true throughout on issues
and on uh it's it's power based and that
bothered me and did i think i could
change the system no i couldn't change
this i said okay come on paul you could
have done it well i did and actually
because i then changed my mind in 2016
when i saw somebody who could do it
and and i got back in the game um
and
do you regret it no not at all no do you
think when you wrote that uh article
thursday of 2016. right before tuesday
saying this guy's going to win it do you
feel that way about him in 2024 that
trump is going to win it
because i don't think desantis is going
to run i don't think desantis wants to
be on the same stage with trump because
it's going to get ugly
oh i don't think desantis runs if trump
runs i agree i think if trump runs
it freezes the field i mean there'll be
somebody whether it's
bill weld again or uh you know
hogan
or
kasich somebody will run
it won't matter trump will trump will
dominate the republican primary on the
republican primary side uh what are the
chances he runs 100 well i think biden
is making it easier every day well biden
won't be running against nobody we all
know that but
you got to look at what you got now we
have to project what's 2024 going to
look like well we have to look at it
through the prism of two things
the biden administration and the 2022
elections the biden administration has
failed on all of the key issues that
trump was succeeding on
and to the point where
i couldn't believe this
there's a i mean i i think the poll is
an outlier poll 19
of the people who voted for him want him
to run again in 2024.
now think about that for a minute but i
did the yeah biden got 80 million votes
19 percent of biden
right you want him to 16 million out of
the that's my point do the math that's
embarrassing
who gave that number what it was i think
it was harris's poll i think it was mark
penn's poll why is that number shocking
though
in one and a half years he's lost 60
million people that voted for
they weren't voting for him paul you
know that but they were voting against
trump you know this well some of them
were but my point is nobody's like hell
yeah but joe's my guy they said donald
trump's not my guy and i'll take anyone
else well we can get into that in a
minute but the point is still to me
that's shocking and
pat picked it up 60 million people who
voted for him within a year have said
i don't want him to run again
that's an incredible number uh and uh
but it but you but now get underneath
the numbers what does it mean
young people why do you think they're
talking about you know student debt
again because young people
i think there's like 60 percent of his
vote in 2020
you know he's down in the 30s 33 of
young people said they would vote for
him if they show up
so you've got an issue on turnout and
then you've got to show up of who turns
out it's not going to you know a third
is going to vote for me you look at
hispanics
this was a movement that was starting in
2016. it was already starting
to move on cultural issues and on the
economy those are the things that are
important to latino in the latino
community
[Music]
trump accelerated that a little bit
and biden in one year as president is
accelerating even more for republicans
uh to the point that we could
republicans could carry a majority of
the hispanic vote
uh in is in 2024. yeah they do it's a
layup to well done that's why it's a
that's why it looks like a layup for
2022. um and what does that mean well
that means that these developing uh
segments of the voting population
are moving away from their traditional
place and once it starts to move it
doesn't just come back
and
what's going to happen as a result of
that in 2023 23 what will happen to my
judgment is the republicans are going to
win both houses of congress more
importantly is what happens in the house
the plurality in the house of the
democratic caucus is going to be the
left
it's going to be the aoc types um maybe
not the leadership but the plurality the
elizabeth warrens on the senate side are
going to be empowered as well so that
the left is going to have more of a
stranglehold on washington
than they do today
in 23. what does that mean for
republicans in 24 and to your question
about trump
the agenda is going to be way out of he
over here when the american people are
here yeah and the
and the governance is making it worse i
mean how does the vocal not realize that
because they don't care about it
what they care about is getting power
they understand the left understands a
very basic thing
first you take power then you create
change
they have to take power first
being the big fish in a small pond is
how they take power
then they'll worry about it because at
the end of the day what is american
politics it's it's two people you
generally running for president you get
one of the two people nominated you've
got a chance to take over the white
house joe biden is the best example of
that um and and so from the left
standpoint they're playing the long game
and they see the opportunity
to take control of the democratic party
in washington in 23
and and then
worry about 24 next elizabeth warren you
know she's already running for president
uh and she's gonna you know she'll
change her strokes here and there but
first she's got to consolidate she
doesn't stand a chance well elizabeth
warren
you know she's not marketable again
again nominations are a different game
oh nomination
yeah but if she gets nominated she's got
a chance i'm not saying she hasn't that
ship all sailed the elizabeth
the bernies
like we've been there done that 2016
2020 they're out here but no we haven't
go
i totally disagree with you i totally
disagree with you 2016 was the i mean
2020 was the wrong time bernie sanders
when we put the strategy together for
for uh trump in 2016
part of the vote that he got and we
targeted it was sanders vote in the
primaries because they weren't leftist
they were
drain the swamp type of people
um and
what's gonna happen is the rhetoric of
2024
is going to be revolutionary on the from
the west
from the left standpoint
um
and again if they can consolidate and
get it in the primaries because in the
private you get through the primaries
the left the democratic primaries are
going to be primaries of the left
not the moderate democrats not the joe
manchins not the joe bidens
the joe i mean
biden emerged from for very uh
specific reasons i always feared joe
biden
i mean he was the one
in fact i did a couple of things you
might be the only person in america no
no here's joe biden what feared him in
2020 feared him why because i thought he
could win why because american
presidential politics when you have an
incumbent running for reelection so it's
not an open seat
it's it's a matter of contrast
well you you said it a minute ago people
were voting against trump right why were
they voting against trump his
personality correct uncle joe
uncle joe hide them in the cl hide them
in the basement you know create this
image of this you know soft gentle
person
uh that's the right image
throw covet on top of that throw
expansion of voting on top of that throw
everything else he gets a chance and he
pulled it off
should he have won no but he did
for that reason so from the left
standpoint
they think they're smarter than that
and
yet joe won so we get control of the
democratic party we'll figure out how to
win the general election against whoever
if it's trump we're going to go add him
hard on trump and and and they'll make
his personality they'll try and make
that the issue
uh and sneak by
with softening elizabeth warren or
softening uh
who you know
buddha judge
um and then figure it out later after
they went so if you like this clip and
you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]